georgia siwa
could you please come see my daughter
and christmas that's cardi b hosting the
2021 american music awards using the
stage to make a simple holiday request
on behalf of her daughter culture turns
out the three-year-old who cardi shares
with her husband offset is a huge fan of
the former dance mom star
my husband he was trying to get georgio
siva right for my daughter's birthday
party but she is she is booked and busy
so georgios
could you please come see my daughter
and christmas you cost a lot of money
let me tell you something y'all rappers
don't got nothing on jojo siwa after
making her plea cardi announced coldplay
and bts's performance and the show went
on
that is until jojo took the stage and
actually responded to cardi's request
you're gonna see what i can do and i'm
gonna try to make christmas happen i
promise
putting it in my phone right now
i take bitcoin actually i take that back
all i need from you is to vote for me
tomorrow night in the season finale of
dancing with the stars
seems like a fair enough ask and in her
typical upbeat jojo fashion the 18 year
old gushed over the rapper alright i
seriously though i cannot wait to meet
culture she is being raised by a
superstar
she's legend cardi b
but jojo isn't the only artist culture
was excited about seeing at sunday's
amas here's what cardi told et ahead of
the award show
i love seeing the collaborations on the
amas and so you got like your girl mega
stallion with bts a new addition and new
kids on stage at the same time are you
kind of excited about anybody
i am excited i'm excited to see bts i
know my daughter she she loves bts i
like her to listen to bts because you
know they're like more like friendly and
they make her dance and all that stuff
so i know she's gonna be excited to see
them she's going to be even more excited
when she hears this personalized message
from the k-pop super group they opened
up to e.t on the red carpet before the
show and well they definitely delivered
tonight's host cardi b she says that her
daughter culture loves you guys and
dances to your music what message do you
have for little culture
let's do it
again you know what's up that's the
culture right there let's go
[Music]